[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا المشاهدين
خطاب الرئيس الموريتاني محمد ولد الشيخ
الغزواني بمناسبه الذكرى الثانيه 68 لعيد
الاستقلال الوطني واعلانه عن زياده
للرواتب والاعانات العائليه ورفعا للحد
الادنى للاجور وتاكيده في سياق الدفاع عن
حصيلته الرئاسيه خلال السنوات الثلاث
الاخيره ان نظامه تمكن من تصحيح ميزان
التوزيع العادل للثروه والتاسيس لتنميه
شامله ومكافحه الاقصاء والتهميش والفقر
والهشاشه
مشاهدينا الكرام عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من
واكشوط الدكتور نور الدين محمد رئيس حزب
موريتانيا الى الامام وهو حزب قيد التاسيس
اا دكتور نور الدين محمد والامريكا مرحبا
شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه الدعوه
مرحبا بكم مرحبا ترحيب مرحبا كل الترحيب
ايضا في الجنب المقابل دائما من وقت شوط
السيد احمد محمد الدوا عضو حزب الانصاف
الحزب الحاكم في موريتانيا اهلا بك ومرحبا
سيد احمد محمد الدروع وكل شك جزيلا لك
ايضا على تلبيه هذه الدعم
اهلا وسهلا بك الكريم
كبير
من جهه وبانتقادات لاذعه من جهه اخرى اولا
قبل ان نتحدث معكم عن المضمون من حيث
الشكل ما تعليقكما على هذا الخطاب الذي
وصف بالمطول اطرح عليك السؤال الاول همم
الدكتور نور الدين محمد رئيس حزب موريتاني
الى الامام
تاسيس مرحبا من جديد
مرحبا شكرا جزيلا اخي الكريم مرحبا بكم
بضيفك الكريم اا طبعا من حيث الشكل هو هو
خطاب مطول جدا انشائي نحن نرحب بهم ونحمد
الله عليه بعد ان كان الرئيس يستعمل
تغريدات على تويتر في المناسبات الكبيره
كالاعياد الدينيه والاعياد الوطنيه من
ناحيه الشكل على الاقل نحن سنرحب بذلك
لكنه او غادر في الاطاله من حيث التفاصيل
الكثيره التي قد يكون خطاب رئيس جمهوريه
في عيد الاستقلال في غناء عنها من ذلك انه
نوع من الاستماته لاستخراج واستمرار كل ما
من شانه ان يعتبر انجازا حتى وان كان
الوعد به انجاز من جديد فكان سردا طويلا
من 13 صفحه تقريبا فيه كثير من الوعود
وليس كصيله في كثير من محاوره همم مع
الاسف ظهرت فيه معلقات كبيره جدا واخطاء
جسيمه
طيب همم
على الاقل انت تقول له فلافي التفاصيل
وانا الخطاب كان مطولا جدا وانشائيا هل
تتفق مع ذلك ضيف سيد احمد محمد الدو عضو
حزب الانصاف الحاكم مرحبا بك من جديد
دائما من حيث الشكل قبل ان نخوض في
المضمون لو سمحت
اهلا بك نور الدين محمد الحقيقه همم لن
همم
هذا النقاش قبل ان احيي بمناسبه ذكرى
الثانيه و 60 لعيد الاستقلال الوطني همم
ابطال مقاومتنا المسلحه والفكريه على ما
قدموا من تضحيات وان واحيي وامجد السائرين
على دربهم من خدمه للوطن على جميع الاصعده
الحقيقه الخطاب اييي خطاب يمكن وصفه بانه
خطاب يليق بالمرحله وانه خطاب من حيث
الشكل
جاء استجابه
وكان
يترجم حقيقه ما حدث خلال السنوات الثلاثه
الماضيه من ماموريه اييه فخامه الرئيس
محمد بن الشيخ الغزواني قد يكون طويلا بعض
الشيء لكن ما الضرر في ان يكون الخطاب
طويلا لكن نتائج هو ستعم الشعب ونتائجه
كبيره جدا
ومرضات الجميع همم لكن
طيب هذا من حيث الشكل لا غير في طول
الخطاب فهو خطاب يليق بالمرحله سيد نور
الدين محمدوه
ولماذا يقبل المرحله لانه اورد ااا هذا
الخطاب اعلانات كثيره وصفت بالهامه جدا
فائده الموريتانيين من هذه زياده الرواتب
زياده هامه في الاعانات العائليه رفع للحد
الادنى للاجور ب 50% الى غيرها من
الاعلانات همم سيد نور الدين محمد من حيث
المضمون الان كيف تابعت انت هذا الخطاب
طيب شكرا طيبكم تفضلوا بالقول قبل قليل
انه سيعم همم ان الخطاب سيكون له فائده
عامه وهذا لا افهمه بهذا الشكل باعتبار
انه اولا زياده الرواتب يجب اعلامكم
واعلام مشاهد الكريم ان انه 95% من
موريتانيا ليست لها رواتب اصلا
وواحد% من الموريتانيين فقط هم من يشتغلون
في الوظيفه العموميه المعنيه في زيادات
خطاب الرئيس ثانيا اذا دخلنا في تفصيل هذه
الزيادات انتم تعلمون ان راتب الادنى الذي
لم ذكره الرئيس انما ذكره فقط زيادته
بالنص لان ذكره في قدر من الاحراج باعتبار
انه لا يصل الى 70 يورو يعني 30 اوقيه
قديمه 30,000 فوقيه قديمه وزيادته وزيادته
ستقيه في مستوى بعيد جدا من المستويات في
المنطقه او من الدول المشابهه موريتانيا
الدول الغنيه بهاراتها الطبيعيه
ومنخجل ان يكون الراتب الادنى فيها لا يصل
الى 100 دولار بل لا يصل الى 80 يورو
وزياده ستحوله الى 120 او 110 يورو همم
لكم ان تتصوروا ذلك ايضا للاسف الشديد
هناك المغالطات كبيره وردت في تحرير
الخطاب حتى لا نقول في كلام الرئيس
احتراما له همم منها قد اعطيكم منها امثله
فقط لانها طويله همم محاربه الفساد مثلا
ان التي توضا الرئيس بذكرها باعتباره
سيشون عليها هو انهم شنوا عليها حرب لاها
ولدت فيها اليوم ضيفكم الكريم او الحزب
الذي يمثله لا يمكن ابدا ان يقول لنا ان
هناك سجين واحد حكم عليهم
ست»
عرضه ولكن نقص دائما
ولكن نبقى في اطار هذه الاعلانات حتى تعود
اليك سيد احمد محمد همم
هامه همم استحسنها كثيرون لقد ترحيبا ولكن
البعض ايضا اعتبرها اما انها متاخره او
مثل ضيفي غير كافي لخلوها ايضا من مساله
خفض الاسعار خاصه وان كما قال ضيفي الفئه
التي تشملها زياده الاجور تبدو ااا محدوده
لست ادري كنت هتتفق معه في هذا الطرح يقول
لك الموظفون العموميون لا يصلون الى 1% من
المواطنين اكثر من 95 من المواطنين ليست
لهم رواتب همم اصلا هل تتفق معه في
محدوديه رؤيته لهذه همم
الاعلانات التي كشف عنها الرئيس في خطاب
همم اخي الكريم لست بصدد همم نقاش من اجل
النقاش اذا اردت ان نتحدث بلغتنا الارقام
وبلغه الواقع فدعونا نخوض همم باقي هذه
الدقائق اذا كان البرنامج من اجل التحاملي
وهذه الشيء من هذا القبيل همم ينبغي ان
تستغل وقتكم في شيء اخر الحقيقه ان
موريتانيا بشهاده همم ابنائها وبشهادتي
العالمي من حولها هي واحه امن في محيط
ملتهب واااا الاوضاع الدوليه والاقليميه
لا تخدم اي من دول الجنوبيه او الدول
الناميه ولا حتى الدول المتقدمه في هذه
الظرف ينحرجه قيد الله لموريتانيا رئيسا
ااه
بالقائدا يحمي الضعيفه
ويوصف القوي رئيس يتحدث ثم عن الرواتب
وتحدثتم عن الحد الادنى للاجور فتحدثوا
ايضا عن
رئيسيا اخذ قرارا بتامين الصحي لمئه الف
مواطن بما يعني اخذنا
ان كل اسره معدل معدل افرادها يكون بينها
5 الى استشخاص حوالي
500,000 مواطن او 600,000 مواطن
خذوه عندكم ايضا ما انجز على الارض من
المستشفيات ومن مدارس ومن ابار ومن الى
غيرها مما ينفع الناس ويمكث في الارض
تحدثوا ايضا ان شئتم عن همم رئيس استلم
بلدا ااه على شفاء اجره نهار همم
ينحره الفساد وهمم ميزانيته ضائعه بين
النهدي
والسرقه
والاختلاس الى ما شئتم من هذه الى هذه
الاوصاف استحدث
لتحسين اموال الدوله ومن ثم تقسيمها على
المواطنين مشكله الرئيس محمد للشيخ
الغزواني انه استاذ مراه خيرات البلد
ثانياتي في المواطن الضعيف المواطن الذي
لا الذي لا يمكنه
استئجار اشخاص من ان يتحدثوا عنه ولا
استئجار مواسات اعلاميه ولا القيام بحملات
من اجل الحديث عن ما انجز من من اجله اخي
الكريم لكم ان تتخيلوا ولل والقارئ او
المتابع المصرف ان يتخيلها انه خلال
الفتره الاخيره التي اجتاحت العالم ازمه
كوفي 19
كان المواطن في موريتانيا يستيقظوا همم في
الثانيه والثالث ليلا فجرا على على الباب
يقرع زي دابه همم افراد من همم
مبتعثين من طرف الحكومه او من طرف مؤسسه
الجيش
يحملون له زاده الشهري وقوته اليومي
تخيلوا ان همم مئات او الالاف من الارامل
ااا
توزع عليهم الاموال شهريا وتم التكفن
بنفقاتهم الشهريه واليوميه وبما يعود لهم
من اقسام تحدثوا ايضا عن عن برامج
لمكافحه سوء التغذيه تحدثوا ايضا عن عن
كثير من هذه الامور ولكن بالله عليكم لا
تبحثوا عن تازين في موريتانيا
في الجانب المقابل من المعارضه ويجيبك وكل
طرف لديه الحق في الدفاع عن رؤيته سواء
افكاره ورؤيه حتى لموريتانيا الغد والعلي
اضيف ايضا لما قام به الرئيس
انك اشرت الى تامين صحي واسع الى ان
موريتانيا تحولت الى واحه امن في محيط
ملتهب الى استثمار في المواطن الضعيف ثم
سيستثمار ايضا همم ثريد من نوعه في
التهدئه السياسيه حتى اعود اليك سيد
نوردين محمد ورئيس نفسه يقول لنا نظامه
تمكن وهذا يحسب له في مناخ سياسي هذا
ومسؤول من تحقيق انجازات هامه قوامها
تصحيح ميزان العداله التوزيعيه الثروه
تقويه الوحده الوطنيه اللحمه الاجتماعيه
التاسيس للتنميه شامله مكافحه الاقصاء
والتهميش والفقر والهشاشه والفساد الذي
كنت همم تتحدث عنه ايضا منذ لحظات
بالاضافه الى همم مساله هامه في اداره
الشان العام وهي مساله تعزيز الحوار
السياسي الانفتاح والتشاور ورغبته في
اشراك الجميع همم العام الا يكفي كل ذلك
شكرا استاذ حكيم اييي بالنسبه طبعا انا
اتفهم الاخ الكريم انه من الحزب الذي
يتسمى بالانصاف انه لم يعد يقبل حتى النقد
يعتبر انه تحاول ونرجع لدهر المدائح وعقود
عقود الشخص الملهم والرئيس المتميز والبيض
من بيض اعتقد هذا ليس حوار ايضا الليله
واللغه الارقام التي اعزف عنها في البدايه
ضيفكم الكريم ثم رجع اليها بشكل غير دقيق
للاسف ايضا هي التي يتكلم عنها اخي الكريم
همم
هذا الرئيس الذي تتحدث هنا عنه ليس بينما
بيننا وبينه مشكله وليس عندنا تحمل فقط هو
رئيس تعاهد بكتاب كتب فيه تعاهداتي وهو
عندي الان الكتاب درسته خلال سنوات ثلاثه
انما هي ارضيه من اجل العمل رئيس تعاهد
بتشغيل 100,000 مواطن موريتاني الرئيس عاد
باختلاء بمما حين هذه اقلاع عن اقتصاديا
فشل ذريعه الرئيس تعهد فان ذاتيه في
الخضروات والفواكه والحبوب او في الخضروات
والحبوب على الاقل اذا كان في خبر كان
الرئيس تعاهد بناء 10,000 وحده سكنيه كانت
في خبر كان تعاهد ايضا بتحقيق الرفاه
للشعب الموريتاني في سنه والشعب
الموريتاني اليوم شبابه
يصعدون في حيطان المكسيك والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اخي الكريم هناك
مغالطات كبيره وردت في خطاب السيد الرئيس
هي هي منها ترسيخ مبدا فصل السلطات
والسلطات غير موجوده حتى اصلا حتى تفصل هي
مهنه الجهاز الهمم
المؤسسه العسكريه والعسكر على الجهاز
التنفيذي وحده ويكفي لنقد لنقد مساله
السلطان ايضا المدرسه الجمهوريه اخي
الكريم التي تطرق لها الرئيس في خطابه
بالتفصيل هي وكلوبه كبيره بالاضحوكه لانها
لانها لا يوجد الان الوزير ولا رئيس ولا
مسؤول كبير يدرس ابناءه في المدرسه
العموميه ولباسها اضحوكه لباس الاطفال
لباس المدرسي الذي عرضهم للثانيه ثانيه
اصبح يسبب سخريه لنا من الجيران ومن
الاخوه همم ايضا محاربه الفساد التي ذكرت
همم زميل لو طيبكم الكريم قبل قليل لا
يوجد الليله السجين واحد حكم عليه ولا
بيوم واحد من السجن بسبب الفساد فان محاره
الفساد يا اخي محكمه الحسابات التي لم تعد
تنشر تقاريرها اصلا المفتشيه العامه
للدوله ليس لها اي اثر اكتشفت 60 مليون 60
مليار اوقيه من امين الاختلاسات ومن
الضباب
تحقيق العشريه في حدود في حدود 100 مليون
يورو 40 مليار اوقيه قديمه لم يسجن فيه
الليله احد وليس به موقوف حتى الليله فاين
محاربه الفساد الحقيقه اخي الكريم اننا
احنا مننا في موريتانيا منذ عقود من
الكلام من الديباجات ومن المدح ومن الرئيس
الحقيقه ان بلد يرزح تحت الفقر والاهانه
والانحطاط التعليم وترهل العداله وفشل
الاقتصاد فشل ذريعا وهو عنده 720 كلمات
متر من اغنى شباط العالم بالاسماء وعندنا
من الغاز في موريتانيا ما هو يصل الى تسع
الى 10 احتياط احتياط الغاز القطري ونحن
الدوله فقيره همم الشعب الموريتاني لا يصل
الى خمسه ملايين سا دي دي رقعه ارضيه همم
قد ضعف الدوله الفرنسيه الحاليه التي انتم
فيها الان
جميع المؤشرات تؤدي ان تقول ان موريتانيا
يجب ان تكون دوله متطاوله لا نمدح الرئيس
انه زاد راتب المعلم ب25 يورو شهريا خلال
سته اشهر لعمرو كما ضاقت بلادهم باهلها
ولكن احلاب الرجال تضيق المشكله اخي
الكريم المشكله في انه حابين التي تصفق
لابسط الامور وتفهيه رئيس الاسد الجديد
قرا كتاب
الرئيس ورد في خطابه الطويل ان هناك كراسي
وهناك كتب مطبوعه وبعضها كانه خطاب همم
يعني موريت في بعض المقاعد كانوا مورد
عاما وجوهريا طيب صحيح يقول البقر سيد
احمد محمد الارث همم ثقيل ورئيس لا يملك
عصا سحريه ولكن موريتانيا بلد فيه ثروه
همم كبيره همم النقائص في مازالت همم
كثيره والاجراءات تبدو وكانها غير كافيه
هل تتفق معه في تش هذا
اسمح لي اولا ان اطالبه وهو همم الاستاذ
الجامع يعني يرفع من مستوى قاموس الفاضي
همم مورد والشيء من هذا القبيل لا يليق ب-
همم ان ان ان يصف به رئيس دوله هو احد
مواطنها على الاقل ثم الاحترام
هذيك مغالطه اخي الكريم
حكيم اسمح لي اسمح لي اولا انا اعرف
الاستاذ نور الدين محمد واعرف ان انه ربما
يكون هذا سبق سبق لسان واعرف ان اخلاقه
ليست لا تسمح له بمثل هذه العبارات لكن
لكن لم يكن بوسعيا هذه الكلمه هكذا
الاحترام
طيب
اتمنى ذلك على كل حال ان ان يقوده محاوله
التفهمي الى همم حقاق بعض الامور
اولا ليس هذا زمن التطبيق ولست من
المطببين وليس هذا الا لما كنت لما كنت
اوصف اعلاميا ومحليا بانني المغاضب وبانني
ااا المشاكس في الاغلبيه هذا هذه اولا
ثانيا اااه
الحقائق على الارض تقول همم غير ما ذهب
اليه الاخ نور الدين الحقائق على الارض
تقول بان هنالك اشخاص ادمن اتخاذ ميزانيه
الدوله وخيراتها دوله بينهم وبعض الاشخاص
المقربين منهم كان الواحد منهم الى يتم
معالجته في فرنسا وفي امريكا وفي همم احد
الدول المتقدمه كان بامكان الواحد منهم ان
همم
عن طريق الوساطه ان همم
يسعى الى ان يمر الشارع
المعبد من امام بيته وحتى ان يكون قصره
المشيد ااه مبنيا على ساحه عموميه للاسف
هذا همم لم يعد موجود للاسف هذه بين قوسين
لم يعد موجود
وليس من الموصي في انه طالب هؤلاء الى
اشخاص الذين ادمنوا مثل هذه الامور ان
يكونوا في صف الرئيس الذي انصف المواطن
ووقف الى جانبه اخي الكريم نحن نتحدث عن
رئيس جاء في ظرفيه همم حرجه دوليا همم في
دوله همم كما اسئله كما اسلفنا لم تكون
لديها همم همم
بنيه تحتيه وليست همم ولا تنتجوا حتى ابسط
الفواكه ولا حتى الخضروات ولا تنتج ال همم
اي شيء من ما تستخدمه جاء هذا الرئيس وضع
تصورا لجميع هذه الامور واخذ الطريقها الى
الانتاجيه وفي نفس الوقت الذي كان العالم
يعاني من من
استغناء كثير من المؤسسات عن بعض عمالها
وهمم
الوجول بعض الاخر الى همم الى الحد من من
الى
التخفيض الرواتب موريتانيا
كانت تاثرها
بالجايحه ومن بعدها ازمه الحرب اوكرانيا
ضعيفه جدا ضعيفه على الحدود وذلك بفضل
الحكمه والحنكه والاراده
والتسيير الجيد وتحسين المال العام في
وجهه من تعودوا نهبه وسبه واتخاذه دوره
بينهم هذه هي هي
نتحدث ايضا نتحدث ايضا عن عن توفير
التامين الصحي والادويه للكثير للكثير من
المواطنين وتوفير
بعض العلاجات طيب
العلاجات مجانا لجميع المواطنين
عن دوله عن دوله تم فيها الفصل بين
السلطات وعصرت القضاء وتعزيز استقلاليته
يتحدث الاخ عن انه لا يوجد الان مفسد
ايييي
في السجن نعم قد لا يوجد لكنه متابع
قضائيا
بطريقه
محاربته للصور الاجتماعيه النبطيه السلبيه
التي كانت تؤرق المجتمع
به في حرب داوس
حققه في الدقيقه المتبقيه همم لا شيء
يتغير بين عشيقه دكتور نور الدين محمد
وهمم الرئيس يقولون ان وكانه بدا من السفر
في مجالات عديده سوكا
الاقتصاديه والصحيه او الامنيه الى غير
ذلك رئيس نفسها اقر بان البناء لم يبلغ
بعد تمامه ولا يمكنه همم ذلك في سنتين او
حتى ثلاث مع انه احرز في سبيل تشيده تقدما
معتبرا لا يجب ان ياخذ هذا بعين الاعتبار
واخذ معك في اقل من دقيقه لو سمحت
شكرا اخي الكريم همم طبعا الامور بالتدرج
كلها ونحن تفهم بذلك لكن المعايير معروفه
والمؤشرات معروفه ونحن هنا لسنا بصدد حديث
عن الشخص لا لذمه ولا لمده حين نحترم
الرئيس ونحترم المسؤولين كلهم واخلاقيات
هنا كما ستفضل للاخر لا تسمح لنا بدائيه
لكن نحن نناقش خطاب انتم ليله قربتم ان
يكون نقاش راح هو خطاب وليس وليس شخص صحيح
الكلام عن كل رئيس يبدا من الصفر هذه هذه
الاغنيه نعرفها في الدول المتقنيه كلها كل
ما جاء رئيس قيل انه بدا من الصفر ويكفيك
ان تنظر الى التلفاز او اذا اذاعه
موريتانيا في كل مره يبدا كل رئيس من
الصيغه ويلعن من قبله وهذا هو الحدث الان
يعني يتكلم عن القنوات غير كريم الاسعار
الاسعار موريتانيا الان ما لم يقوله
الرئيس في خطابه وما لم يذكره همم ضيفكم
الكريم هو ان اسعار اللحوم والزيوت
والحبوب والخضروات في في مستوى غير نسبه
في تاريخ موريتانيا الوقود تم زيادهته
اكثر من 30% دفعه واحده يعني وقود الان في
موريتانيا ارخص منه في تونس العاصمه
الليله والحس في ذكر وارخص في غريب من
موريتانيا رغما عن ان القدره الشرعيه اضع
في موريتانيا وهذه فضيحه هذه فضيحه
الاسعار متدربه اذا اقصى درجه اخي الكريم
زياد الحقيقيه التي يستفيد منها المواطن
هي هي الاسعار الاسعار هي العامه هي التي
انفعلها الرئيس رحبنا بها ومدحناه احسن
المدح لكن ان تزيد رواتب زياده طفيفه
وتكون رواتب عندها 1% من الناس هذه لا
يمكن ان نصفي الاخر
10 سنوات
محاوله مقارنه موريتانيا مع الدول الاخرى
المنتجه للفواكه
حتى مجددا لم يتحدث عن الرئيس بل تحدث عن
وسائل الاعلام والاحترام مكفول لكل
الاطراف مثل هذا دائما في حلقاتنا وعلى
قناتنا كلنا نشوف جزيلا لكم الدكتور نور
الدين محمد رئيس حزب موريتانيا الى الامام
قيد تاسيس هذا الحزب السيد احمد محمد
الددو حزب الانصاف الحاكم تماما معنا في
فقره وجه لوجه من الوشود شكرا جزيلا لكم
من جديد